no not another JavaScript framework
please don't we have enough of those but
what if I told you that this isn't
actually a framework it's a compiler
mind blow
all right hello class and welcome to
this video where we learn about what's
felt is and then use it to create an app
that implements full production allottee
by using an API that I created a while
ago for video to which a link is in the
description and the link for that API as
well will be in the description more on
that later
so what is felt and what makes it
different to the other ones so like
angular react and view felt is a UI
framework for creating component based
single page applications the catch is
that felt takes a different approach in
that it doesn't have framework code
that's actually bundled with your
application it actually goes over your
code in build time and then compiles all
of your code into instructions in
written and purely JavaScript
leading to a very lean bundle size
because later your bundle wouldn't have
any code that's relevant to felt itself
is just your own code that you have and
spelt as well takes a reactive approach
when we render in your Dom and and it
doesn't have a virtual Dom so it doesn't
work by come rather comparing a virtual
Dom to an actual Dom and then seeing the
difference and then we rendering the
difference instead it watches over a
couple of variables that you define and
then whenever any of those change it
actually rear-end this the Dom so they
take great pride in that it takes less
code doing the same thing you could do
the same thing in react and do it in
felt and it will be less code when you
write it in felt you can actually go
here to learn more and write less code
and you will see a couple of examples
they show that for example this is with
these two fields and calculating the sum
between them this is what it would look
like if you would write it and react
using hooks and then this is what it
would look like if you write it in felt
and I've played around with felt and
it's actually pretty cool how less code
you get to write and even like the
template syntax itself is very minimal
it's got some really cool features now
this doesn't mean it's gonna replace
react or anything react still has a lot
of like improvements during the runtime
and some other cool features that are in
the bundle itself so yeah I guess it's
up to your preference now if you are
saying now I want to learn more about
spelt you can go to spell toor dhal the
dev rather and learn more about it and
if you want to like understand like this
the idea behind it and the philosophy
behind it I highly recommend this talk
by rich harris the guy that made the
framework himself this talk is called
rethink and reactivity I'll put a link
to this as well in the description it's
a really cool talk that kind of explains
why's felt was made alright so this is
the application that we're going to
build in this video so it's got this
post is pulling them from the API so
it's fetching these posts and showing
them here and we can add some more new
posts so you can click Add here using
that form and we will actually submit it
to to a server and fetch the response
back and if we reload is still there
because of the way the API works we can
as well edit these like just type some
others of gibberish here and click
update and it will be edited and we can
delete these posts you can limit the
number of posts and we have this knob
bar right here and we have like two
pages that we can navigate between just
to show you like how to do routing
installed so the idea behind this app is
that you get to learn some of the core
things that you would do in most
front-end applications like handling
forms consuming a full crud api and
routing as well so let's actually jump
into the code alright so on the is felt
main page let's go down and get this MPX
command from here let's copy this and
I'll go to my desktop and open up a
terminal window and paste this command
and we don't have to name it my felled
project we can name it anything I'll
just name it spelled for now and hit
enter and now we need to see the
internet also I'll say CDs felt and here
we need to run npm install because it
hasn't installed the dependencies yet
and i'll open it using vs code and let
it
stall so if we look at the package.json
we noticed that we have a couple of
scripts and we're gonna use the dev
script to build and run the app on a
development server and if you notice
here there isn't any dependencies it's
just dev dependencies because it doesn't
need any dependencies in production it
only needs them in built time to compile
the app so here I think it's done
installing it has let's run npm run dev
and see what our application looks like
alright it started already so let's go
to port 5000 yeah and there we go we
just get a purple hello world so let's
look at our app so we go to the source
folder and we have this mange is that
instantiates the new is felt app and
passes some props to the apps felt just
to show you how props work they did that
and here we get the prop and here we put
the prop inside the mark-up saying hello
name if you notice we if you change this
name to hello YouTube or just YouTube it
will now say hello YouTube alright so
let's get rid of these props because
we're not gonna use them and let's get
rid of this export name and this style
as well and by the way in spelt if
you've worked with view you're familiar
with this with this kind of syntax you
have a script tag where you put your
logic you have a style tag where you put
your styling and you have your markup
the only difference here you don't have
a template tag you just put your markup
down here and cool thing is if you're
using prettier and by the way I
recommend you get the felt where is it
right here the spelt vs code extension
to have syntax highlighting inside of
your app or I mean inside of your dots
felt files alright let me close that
close this now before we write any
markup I want to grab materialized CSS
which is a cool CSS and implementation
of Google material material design
standards it's got to get started and
here it tells us to install materialized
CSS up next so let's do that so here I
stopped the development server and say
npm install materialized - CSS at next
like this okay now we need to link the
CSS we could link here we will but by
default the build tool for the bundling
tool for spelt is roll up instead of web
pack and it comes with very minimal
setup so we need to actually install a
plugin for this for it to actually
recognize CSS files inside of this
felled files and bundle them into a CSS
file in production so here I'm gonna
install a rollup plug-in so here I'll
say NPM install roll-up plug-in CSS only
and they say - capital D for it to be a
dev dependency alright now in the
roll-up config I'm gonna add this import
let's import that plug-in so let's say
import CSS from roll-up plug-in CSS only
and then here underneath this spelt call
we're gonna say CSS we call that
namespace that imported that function
and here for the options we just pass
output and here we will pass a CSS file
that would be all the bundled CSS that
we pass through our app so here I'll say
public slash extra dot CSS so what this
plug-in now will do it will find any CSS
that we inject into svelt files and
bundle all of it into this extra CSS
file and it will be in the public right
here so we need to link it in our
index.html so here let's link it before
our actual CSS so here we'll say link
and we say the H ref will be extra dot
CSS even though it doesn't exist yet but
it will
let's change the title here so say is
felt tutorial let's save this and let's
go back to our app svelt now we can
actually import CSS into this felt file
so here we'll say import now that we
have materialized installed we can say
import we go back one level to node
modules oops
node modules slash materialized
CSS slash dist slash CSS so I
materialize our CSS dot min actually
materialized dot min dot CSS like this
we can just copy this to get the the
JavaScript and here we'll say /j s and
here will be the min dot J's like this
now let's let's save everything and
let's run our after ganda C and PM run
dev and now we see that it created this
extra CSS and it's got materialized
stuff as you see here and it's actually
linked materialized and if we would look
at our app where is it right here if we
reload we get that it's the header is
now styled with materialized CSS had a
one styling cool so we have materialized
linked I want to start by putting a nav
bar at the top of the page to link to
different pages now of course the about
page is empty I'm just using it to show
you how to do routing in stealth so
we're gonna use this felt routing
library because by default to the
routing library it doesn't come with
felt so this is how do we use it we need
to run this command right here so let's
copy that and let's open up a new window
terminal window and paste that command
so if we look at the library here it
tells us how to use it it tells us to
import these things from spell routing
so we can we can copy this and let's go
to our app app dots felt can close these
you don't need them anymore so here we
will import this router and link and
route from spell routing and now we can
set up our router here so here we'll say
router and then here we will start to
put our routes but the way I want to do
it I want to put them in an app but I
don't want to put them right here I want
to put them out buying its own component
so let's go to actually I close that
let's go to materialise CSS go to
components and right here navbar let's
grab this knife tag and let's go back
copy that and let's click here let's
create rather a new component and I'm
put this in a folder called layouts I'll
say layout slash nav bar dot spelt and
here we'll just paste that
let's change logo to say spelled
tutorial and let's change these let's
just have two pages so one would be the
homepage and one would be the about page
and we need to create these components
as well and now these shouldn't be a tax
they need to be links for our spelt
router to work so here we'll change this
anchor tag to link like this link of
course we need to import it so here we
need to put our script tag and here we
will say import link from spelt -
routing like this now we can use that so
we can change this well the the brand to
link like this we need to add a to
attribute instead of href and this is
the home so we'll say - slash and now we
have this home link here as well so
we'll say - slash like this and we will
change this to a link and this is the
about page so we'll say - slash about
and change this here to a link as well
now let's go back to our app here we
need to put our navbar so we need to
import it so let's go here and say
import navbar from and on the same level
we go to the layout folder and we get
this navbar and here of course we have
to add felt because it's not a
JavaScript file we need to explicitly
say what the extension is now that we
have navbar we can actually use it in
our markup so let's put it inside the
router so let's say like this navbar
oops
apparently I didn't copy that so I can
just say now bar like this and
underneath here I want to put a
container to push everything into the
middle this is by the way just
materialized stuff and here we need to
put our routes and if we would look at
the page for the package our routes are
like this and by the way you can ignore
this you are
thing this is only if you're using
server-side rendering so don't worry
about that and let's copy one of these
routes copy the second one actually and
let's go back here we need to put routes
so let's put the home route the path
will be just slash and the component
will be home and by the way you can use
the syntax but you can as well omit
these quotation marks they're not
important so they're not necessary so
let's put another one here and say slash
about and this will be to the about
component let's create these two pages
I'll create another folder call it pages
this is what convention that I like to
separate pages from components this is
not a spell come convention so here I'll
say home that's felt and I'll create
another one as well call it about dot
felt and in the about I'm just gonna put
a header one saying about page just to
differentiate between them and here for
now let's put a home page and we'll come
back to it of course and populate it
more and here we don't need link so you
can remove it because the links are in
the nav bar and we need to import these
two components so here let's say import
home from same level pages slash home
that's felt and then we can copy that
paste it one more time select home and
ctrl D and say about all right let's
save all files and let's look at our
terminal everything is running fine if
we look at our app right where is it
right here for reload cool we get the
snap bar and it's linking between the
pages but it looks kind of weird let's
look at our app I think it's got to do
with the global styles yeah there are
some global styles here I'm just gonna
delete all of them and let's look back
to our up because we're gonna use the
materialized styling alright let's put a
container actually to push these buttons
in and for some reason this brand isn't
the font size is tiny on that so
actually let me check that to inspect
it's actually not applying the class to
it so let's go back here
to the navbar the brand logo class is
not being applied so what we can do we
can just wrap this as well tutorial with
a span with this class so we'll give
that class brand logo and then take that
put it inside of here and then wrap
everything here so let's cut everything
inside of this nerve repair and put a
dot container tab and then paste back
those links and let's save and there we
go now the the the navbar logo class is
applied so the text is bigger there and
the links are pushed in inside so the
routing is working now we can start to
work on the content on the home page
let's start to hit our API and fetch the
posts and show them here so let's go to
our app let's go to the home dots felt
file and we can close this close the
global CSS and app and everything else
and here I'll put a row and inside of
here we want to show our posts but of
course we need to hit the API first and
fetch these posts so here I'll open the
script tag let me close this terminal
here inside the script tag what we want
to do we want to fetch these posts when
the component loads or mounts so we need
to import this lifecycle method called
unmount so let's say import on mount
this is in the documentation of course
from felt and here let's let's bring our
API base URL so here I'll say Const a P
I base URL because we will need this to
call the API this is in the description
in the video description and here let's
initialize our posts object as an empty
array at the beginning so now let's call
this unmount method and say unmount and
this takes a callback that happens when
the component is mounted and this is
gonna reach for for this is gonna hit
the API so I'm gonna make it an async
callback so here I'll say async oops
and here it's gonna be an arrow function
and inside the V I'll say result or rest
equals a weight the fetch I'm gonna use
fetch API
and I'm gonna give it the API base URL
plus slash posts like this this is the
route that gives us all the posts and
here we'll say posts our so this
variable right here equals a wait wait
res dot oops Jason like this so the way
fetch works is that you need to as well
return a response dot Jason and this
returns a promise with the data that's
got from that request and now when we
assign a value to post our component
will actually rerender now let's use
these posts to display them on the
template here I want to loop through
these posts so first I want to do a
conditional because if we're still
fetching the post I want to show loading
posts so here we'll open curly braces
and do hash if and this is felt template
syntax and we'll say posts the length
equals zero so if the length of posts
equals zero that means we haven't got
posts yet so I'll do a header three and
say loading posts dot dot dot so you can
put a spinner here if you want and here
we'll say : else so else if we have any
posts if it's not 0 the length we want
to loop through them so we'll open
another JavaScript expression and say
hash
each or just an expression and say posts
as post like this the this is kind of
similar to PHP if you've worked with it
this syntax post as post so here we'll
say they've call dot as 6 this is
materialized stuff I want each post to
take half the width of the viewport of
or like the width of the container and
here I'm going to put a card so dot card
and inside the card we need card content
so dot card content and inside that div
I'm gonna start with the title so that
we say paragraph P dot card title inside
of here we'll do curly braces to put
dynamic values and now that we have
access to this post we can use what
comes inside of the post by the way you
can call credit this API on postman or
something and you'll find that posts
have a body I created that a user ID and
and the title so here we'll need to say
the title because this is the card title
so we'll say post dot title like this I
want to show is well the created at so
here we'll say P and I will say curly
brace post created ad like this and
let's put the body of the post so here
paragraph another one and say post dot
body like this here we need to close the
each tag so here we'll say we open curly
braces and we say slash each and this
will close that tag and here we need to
close as well this if statement so he
will say curly brace slash if like this
alright let's save this and see what
this looks like let's go to our app and
there we go we're getting three posts
which are all the posts are on the
database right now if we reload
we'll see loading posts for like a brief
second before the actual posts load all
right so let's add the two buttons for
editing and deleting and I want to style
this a bit to make it look better than
that let's go back so underneath this
div this card content div I'm gonna add
dot card action and here we'll have two
links so one anchor tag which doesn't go
anywhere and this is gonna be the edit
post so here we'll say edit and I'm just
gonna copy this and add another one
which is gonna be delete and I'll give
this a class to two later style it so
I'll give it a class of delete - BTN
let's save let's see what these look
like alright they look okay and I want
to style this delete button so here
let's open up a style tag and by the way
these styles are scoped to these
components so any style I write here
will not go to any other component even
if the component is inside of here so
here we'll style the delete buttons also
dot delete
- BTN I just want to give it like a
color of red and I'm gonna give this
important for it to apply and I want to
style the cards titles all saved card
card
content dot card title to target that
and I just wanna that there's this
syntax completion is a bit weird with
this extension right now but I guess
that will be fixed in the near future
because this is fairly new so here we'll
say margin-bottom I want to give it a
margin bottom was zero and I want to
style as well the this date they created
that so I'm going to give it a class or
is this right here can give it a class
of time stamp and here will say so we
can just copy this instead of card title
this will be P dot time stamp and I'll
just oops I'll just give this a color of
like gray like hash nine nine nine and
I'll give it some margin bottom so it
separates itself from the body
it's a margin bottom of ten pixels all
right let's see what this looks like all
right it looks better so let's go back
now we can make these into a component
by itself but we're gonna make some
other components so I'll show you how to
make components anyways here let's give
these two buttons I call back like like
a function that will be triggered when
they're clicked and for this we're gonna
use the on directive so here we'll say
on colon and now we give the type of the
event so here we're gonna give the event
click and then say equal and open an
expression and here we can pass a
function that will be triggered once
this button is clicked so here I'll pass
a callback because otherwise it will
trigger it right when the component is
rendered and here I'll say edit post and
pass it this post and here as well we're
going to give a delete another event so
here I'll say on :
click equals and here I'll give a call
back to
delete post and I'm gonna pass the post
ID and we're gonna implement these later
but for now I'm just gonna have them
print something to the console okay
there's a mistake here all right like
this let's go up here in the script tag
let's create these two functions so here
we'll have edit whoops edit post and
we'll take a post and for now it's just
gonna console.log it so just console.log
post like this actually I need to use
the keyword function let's create the
delete post as well so function delete
post will take an ID and for now I'm
just gonna say deleting post with ID and
just concatenate that ID let's save
let's see if these are running properly
so let's open the developer tools the
console and I'm gonna put this
side-by-side and here if I press edit on
this it doesn't do anything let's go
back okay I made a mistake here let's
save that let's go back to our app
refresh and here if I click Edit there
we go it's printing that post that we
clicked on edit and if I click delete it
says deleting post with id something
something which is the idea of this post
alright cool so let's go back to our app
let's create the form that we will use
to submit a post to the server so on top
of this row I'm gonna add another row at
the top here and say the row and here
I'm gonna have it take half the width so
I'll say Col dot s6 tab and inside of
here don't worry about that pretty old
format it I'm gonna put the form but I'm
not gonna put the whole form here I'm
gonna just put the component and make it
into its own component so here I'll say
post form and then just leave it like
this and let's import that and then
create it so here I'll say import post
phone from I'm gonna create a folder
call it components and actually here
we're inside pages so we have to go back
one level and then say components slash
post form dot felt like this and here
let's create this folder
components and inside of components I'm
gonna create the post form dot felt so
here we'll write our formula say oops
we'll say form don't know why phone
didn't work I'll just save form like
this and this will have a submit event
so we'll say on and the the event will
be submit submit oops
mint equals and we will call a function
that will call on submit like this and
let's close this form and inside the
form will have a div with the class
input field and this is materialized
stuff just to style it with the
materialized here will have two fields
one field for the title and one for the
body so here we'll put a label for title
and you will say title like this and
here we'll put the input for that title
of type text and this here what we need
to do is we need to bind the value of
this input with a value in our component
with a variable so misspelt has a
two-way binding meaning that we can use
the directive called bind and then give
say : value equals now we want to give
an the name of the value that we're
going to use which we'll call title
which we haven't created yet but we will
so now whenever title this input changes
it will change title in our component
and if title is well changes the value
of the input will change this is what
two-way binding means so let's copy this
entire input field and paste it here and
here we'll change this is a label for
body and this was a body and this
variable here is where we'll be called
body let's add a submit button so say
button of type submit so : submit and
click tab and we'll give it some classes
to style it with materialized CSS
styling who say waves affect waves light
and bTW and as well and this button will
say add because they adds a post and
here let's open a script tag and I don't
know if it's the is felt extension or if
it's prettier
it's probably this felt extension but
you can put the script tag underneath
the the markup and if you save the
script tag will go up to the top which
is pretty cool and the same thing with
style because logically Styles should be
before before the HTML because that's
how cascading style sheets work and if I
save the style tag we'll go up above the
template which is pretty cool all right
so let's go to the script so here we'll
declare these two variables the title
and the body so we'll say let title
equals an empty string and let body
equals an empty string all right now we
don't have any red squiggly lines but we
have this green squiggly line telling us
that it's not the onsubmit is not
defined so let's fix that here we'll say
function on submit and we'll say it
takes an event and of course first thing
we do is say event prevent the fault
like this don't know why added that
underscore prevent the fault like that
and here I'll do like a very basic
validation and say if title the trim
equals then always replacing these
functions equals an empty string or body
dot trim don't know it's changing this
trim is a JavaScript function this is a
bit weird but let's bear with it if any
of these two is an empty string then we
just return because we don't want to
submit this because this is invalid data
you can of course show some validation
errors but that's kind of JavaScript I
want to focus on svelte more for this
tutorial so if not we have these fields
then let's form this post and send it to
our server so here we'll say constant
you post is an object which will have a
title of the value of title so we can
just say title like this and body like
this now let's bring our base URL from
here let's copy this and put it right
here and now we need to send a request a
post request to our database to persist
this post so we'll say actually we'll
use async await so here we can make this
an async function we add the async
keyword and
he will say Const response equals a wait
fetch we do backticks and here we'll say
dollar sign curly-brace api base URL and
we concatenate slash post because this
is the router that we post to here we'll
say comma and we pass some options
including the method so the method will
be a post so method post like this and
the body of the request will be json dot
stringify or just string of stringify
like this stringify and we pass it the
new post that we just created so now
when we get that data now we need to get
the post from that data so we'll say
Const post equals a wait res dot jason
oops
don't always change these variables it's
bit annoying it's very strange
okay let's save all files and let's look
at our app and we broke it on submit is
not defined okay okay because hey this
is a capital S don't submit like this
alright so we get our form and if we
type anything here so let's say post
from spelt if we leave this empty you
shouldn't submit anything and it doesn't
and if we type some gibberish it would
click add I think it does and a request
if we look at network post alright so it
sends a request and the status code is
201 so it's been created of course we're
not adding any code to show it here but
if we refresh we see that that post has
indeed been posted I want to do
something here I want to have a loading
boolean and when we send a post it will
actually show us a spin a bar that that
indicates that we're actually
communicating to a back-end so here I'll
create another variable call it loading
so let loading equals initially it will
be false and here when we submit the
form if it's valid then first thing we
want to do we want to set the loading to
true so we'll say loading equals true
this is as simple as that just a
that we change this variable and this
variable is used in the markup just the
fact that we reassign it to a different
value it's actually going to re-render
our our markup so we set the loading to
true and then we communicate to our
server and once everything is done we
set the loading back to false so we say
loading equals false false like this now
in our markup we let's cut this phone
and here let's do curly braces hash if
and we'll say if not loading then we
want to show this phone and then here
let's say else so : else and here else
if we're loading let's do dot progress
and this is materialized CSS stuff and
here we'll say dot in determinate and
this will give us like an indeterminate
loading bar or progress bar so here
we'll finish close the if statement will
say slash if like this and let's save
let's go back to our app now if we put
some stuff here and we hit add there we
go we see that loading bar for a second
and then it goes away once the loading
stops let's actually make that loading
bar go a bit in the middle and give this
some padding so that it looks a bit
better so let's go back here and what's
cool about spelt is that we don't have
to give this a class and style it just
because this is in just in this
component we can just say form and then
style style this form and none of the
other forms in any other page will get
the style because this is scoped to this
component so here I'm just gonna give it
some margin on all sides of 50 pixels
and here we'll say I want to start the
progress bar source a progress and I'll
give this a margin top and bottom of a
hundred pixels and left and right of
zero so let's save this let's look at
our app so alright go the form looks
much better now and if we submit
something else that bars in the middle
here alright let's work on actually
adding this post to our post list now if
by the way of course I'm getting all of
this from the documentation is felt has
some radical
documentation ago two examples you can
even fiddle with the code and change the
examples and how they work and there's
this thing right here called event
forwarding which is what we're going to
use to communicate between the inner and
the outer components that we have so if
you see here it actually dispatches an
event from inside of a component that's
nested inside this component and then
based on that event the outer component
will perform some action so let's copy
this import from here this create event
dispatcher let's copy that actually it's
copied both of these because we need
that let's go here let's paste this at
the top and you can keep that there and
then after we get the post we want to
dispatch this event so let's dispatch an
event and we just say dispatch like this
let's call this event post created and
we can pass a payload so the payload
will actually be this post now we can
listen to this event on any other
component and then catch that and then
get this payload and do whatever we want
with it so where we want it we want it
in the home page so here in the home
page I'm going to go down here where we
add our form and I'm gonna listen to the
event so I'll say on and here you put
the name of our custom event and say
post created so on this event we're
going to call a function and I'm gonna
call this add post simple as that let's
go up here and create this add post now
we want to create a function that adds
that post that we got to this post array
that we have so here I'll say function
post and if you look at the
documentation you will see that the
event right here actually if we look at
app dot svelte the event has this
property detail which holds our payload
so here in our add post we will we can
destructor it straight away so we will
do structure detail and we can do a
colon and give it another name because
it's because it makes more sense to call
it post here instead of detail because
it's actually a post so here now that we
have that data we just want to add it to
our posts so we can simply say posts
equals and we do an array and we want to
put it at the top so we'll say
, and then we spread our existing posts
like this now be careful with this you
don't want to do a post push or on shift
because when you do that you're not
assigning a new value you're changing
the variable but you're not assigning a
new value so that wouldn't actually
cause the rerender you want to do posts
equal and then you actually add your
data so let's save all files and let's
look our up and see if this is working
just right here let's refresh just in
case and we can say post to be added add
this post and we click enter and there
we go our post is actually added to our
front-end but our form is not resetting
so let's fix that let's go here so in
our form when we submit that and we
dispatch the event we can simply say
title equals an empty string and body as
well or you can say title equals body
equals empty string so we reset both of
them alright let's look at our app
reload just in case and let's put some
gibberish that gets added and the fields
are reset sweet let's now implement this
delete button I mean give it some actual
functionality so let's go here in the
home so we have or we already created
this delete post function but it doesn't
do anything so here we will say fetch
and the way our API works we want to
send to the URL slash post slash the
idea of that post and once send it as a
delete request so here we'll want to
concatenate our with a curly brace
dollar sign curly brace API base URL and
close that curly braces
slash post slash and then concatenate
the ID as well and then here when I pass
some options and in the options we only
want to say that the method is a delete
method and here we can use the the then
syntax and then here we say response and
by the way just because I'm using async
there and then here I wouldn't do it in
a project I'm just showing you that
there are multiple ways of doing this in
one of my projects I'll still stick to
one way of doing things to maintain
readability so here with the response
wanna return rest or JSON like this and
then chain another then where we get
actually we don't need any of the result
that's return nothing gets returned so
we just want to actually remove that
post from our front end so here we'll
say posts equals and we'll say post dot
filter to remove that post and our
filter will be post where post dot
actually post dot ID does not equal this
ID which will now remove all the posts
that don't have this ID I mean keep just
the post that don't have this ID meaning
that it will only remove that post so
let's save that let's look at our app
it's pretty low just in case if we
delete this it actually goes away if we
delete this it goes away let's add a
pop-up like a confirmed pop-up that you
know just in case people don't delete
everything by mistake so let's copy all
of this here will say if confirm and the
confirm will say are you sure so if they
click OK on that we actually want to
send that post that I mean that request
and now if you click delete access asks
are you sure if you click OK actually
deletes it alright let's now work on the
edit button so let's go here so this is
called from the post one or actually not
from the home so what we want to do now
is that we want to when we click on edit
we want to pass the details of that post
down to this form and then populate the
fields of that form with those details
so here when we edit a post we've got
one gonna set a new property here I was
call it an editing post and initially
this will be will have a body that's an
empty string a title that's an empty
string and an ID that's no because the
way our API works when we want to edit a
post we want to send the body and the
title and the ID as well to know which
opposed to edit on the database so
now
we won when we edit post we want to set
this editing post to this post that we
clicked to edit so we'll say editing
post equals this post that we got here
simple as that but we want to pass this
editing post to the to the post form as
a prop we can do post editing post
equals editing post like this but when
we save it's gonna change it to like
some really nice minimal syntax that
I've been wishing that it would happen
on react a while ago which is just doing
curly braces editing post which was
which is gonna give that prop with that
name and that value to our post form as
well now we want to use that in this
component and display those details so
let's go up here now
what we can do we can say title equals
editing post title up here so we can say
let's title equals editing post the
title and do the same thing for body
actually I haven't tested this I don't
think it will update once week yeah we
won't update see there's a problem says
editing post is not defined okay I know
why because I we need to declare editing
posts as a prop that we can that we can
get from outside so we need to say
export let remember like that that was
on the app as well for the property name
so we can need to say the same thing for
editing post when I say export let
editing post this will tell this
component that we can receive this as a
problem so let's save now if we look our
up so that's fine but the problem now
they're set to an empty string but if we
click edit it will not change because
it's not tracking any changes the way we
fix that we can just use this syntax we
can say dollar : and we can do the same
thing for body here and this will we
will tell our component will be like
look we will assign this value but
whenever editing post title changes then
assign that value again to title so this
is
reactive to editing post so if we save
this now that should fix it so here if
we click Edit there we go we get the
details from this component I mean from
this post to our form right here so if
click here we get those and we click
here we get those that's pretty cool I
want to as well change the button from
add to update once we are in actually
editing mode so there's a simple trick
so right here once our editing post has
some value when we click here it will
also have an ID because by default it's
not so we can use that as a conditional
so down here instead of just add we will
put an expression so we'll do curly
braces and we'll say editing post don't
ID question mark so if this is not null
we will say update else if this is known
that means we were an ad or we're in
creating mode we'll say add let's save
that let's look at our app so by default
it says add when the ID is known but
when we click on edit it becomes update
cool let's now add the logic for
actually reaching to our server and
updating this post all right let's go
back so this will happen through the
onsubmit as well of course but now what
we need to do we need to add a new thing
here we will say because if we have an
ID we will actually send a post request
to API slash post slash that ID and then
it will be a request to edit that post
with that ID so here we can just say
condition and will say if editing post
dot ID so if it's not null then we're
gonna actually update a post we're gonna
form a URL let's say actually here we
can say actually we need to declare
these outside because we won't need them
later so we'll say let will create these
two variables URL and method as well
because the method could be either a
post or a put so here we'll say you are
all equals as do backticks
and the form our URL would be api base
URL like this slash post slash this ID
so we can do dollar sign curly brace and
we can just copy and paste that inside
so that's our URL and of course now the
method will be put because we're in edit
mode so we'll say put like this else if
the idea is no that means we're trying
to create a post so the URL will be
backticks and we'll say curly brace and
we'll say api base URL slash post and
the method will be post and now we can
say we can send the same request but
instead we can send it to URL because
this could be different and the method
is just method so we can just omit this
and send the same body here let's save
and this should work so let's look at
our app let's put this side-by-side and
let's look at our network tab let's
clear that and now if we just I'm gonna
refresh just in case now if we just
submit a post but I can't type in these
fields okay I can't type in these fields
because I didn't change these values now
these values should actually be editing
from editing post so here I'll say
editing post dot title and dot body this
should fix that let's go back alright
now I can post I mean I can type alright
so here if I just send this this should
be a post request here it says URL is
not defined
let's see that okay this is URL I don't
know why the autocorrect is changing my
variable names that's very weird
I hope they fix this extension all right
now it should work if I put some
gibberish and click add if I look at the
network tab it sent a post request to
slash post but now if I click on edit
the same one and give it just like a
bunch of V's like this and click update
and if we go back it's right right here
okay so this is the a put request and
it's gone successfully but of course the
problem now it's actually added it
because we didn't change the logic to
add post in the home component so let's
do that let's go to the home component
so here in
post we want to check if we already have
that post then we just want to edit it
we just want to replace it so we'll do
if posts don't find post where post dot
ID equals this post that we got the ID
so if this is true that means we already
have this post that means this post was
probably being edited so we just want to
find the index of it and replace it in
our existing posts so we'll say Const
index equals posts dot find index and we
want to find the index of post where a
post of ID is the same condition that
equals this post or ID now that we have
this index we need to declare a new
array and say let posts updated equal
posts so we're just making a copy of it
right now that we will assign later and
now we want to edit this post updated so
post updated dot splice and we remove
starting from the index we remove only
one and then we replace it with this
post now we can simply say posts so our
post equals posts updated which will
rerender else else we just do this
alright let's save and let's see what
this looks like so now if want to edit
all if one edit this one as well and
change it to like like all exes like
this click update there we go it changes
to all exes and it doesn't add a new one
let's reset the form now the phone
should be reset from here we can't reset
it from inside and this title and body
don't exist anymore so we can remove
that and here we can just assign it
again to this so I can just copy that
and after either of these happen we'll
just do this paste this here alright
let's go back now let's edit these from
these two double use like this and we
click update and the form resets cool
let's add the post limiter that limits
the number of posts right here so let's
go back here let's go down to the markup
and after the forum here I'm gonna add a
column with the width s3 and here I'll
put some text say limit
number of posts and after this I'll put
an input input of type number and this
will have no name or bind it to some
value and I'll call this value post
limit and it won't have any ID close
that tag and after this we'll have a
button and this will have a click event
so on : click I want to call the set
limit and let's give it some
materialized classes waves effect and
waves light and BTN let's close that
button and it will say set
alright let's create this method this
function and this post limit and the set
limit so we go up here say let post
limit and create that function set limit
let's go down here and say function set
limit let's send a fetch we'll say fetch
to send a request and then we can just
copy this so to the base of your URL
slash post slash that number so we'll
put the post limit right here and to get
request and we'd only need to say
anything
we just chain then and when we get a
result we want to return res jason and
here we've chained another than and we
will get to the posts and here we'll say
show again I want to give it a different
name to not conflict with the posts that
we already have and we will say post
equal equals posts data like this
alright let's save everything let's look
at our app lets give it a default value
so it doesn't look empty like that and
let's give it like some margin on all
sides I'm just gonna give it some inline
styling right where is it
so it's this I'm just gonna say style
equals margin 50 pixels like that and we
want to give this post limit ad
value of 6 all right let's save all
right it looks much better now if want
only two posts you click set it doesn't
work it's cuz reference posts oh I made
a typo my bad
so right here this is post snapshots
let's save let's go here when I get two
we set we get two three we get three for
a massive number we get all of them all
right cool
actually I forgot to show you something
let's actually build this app to see the
bundle size of it so here we're gonna
stop this development server or is the
NPM room built
yeah it's NPM run build so say NPM run
build hit enter okay it's built let's
open this open reveal in Explorer so
look at the public the bundle is 196 ok
that's unfair because that most of it is
coming from this materialize jeaious all
right I'm gonna just comment that for
now and build it so NPM run built just
to show you the actual bundle size of
spelt itself alright cool so if you look
at public now it's 21 kilobytes which is
absurdly low and 10 kilobytes or 11
kilobytes of this is actually coming
from spell routing so spelt itself is
only 10 kilobytes I mean this app itself
of course there's no spelled code inside
this bundle is just some JavaScript
instructions with our own code which is
this is insanely small and very
efficient so yeah I hope this gave you
like a good start with felt I hope that
you're excited about it's felt and you
want to use it and learn more about it
thank you very much and I hope to see
you soon bye